yin and yang night and day good and evil
you know all the things you all these
opposites don't matter how political you
are there's always these clashes and we
all know that so in iido we use yin and
yang but it's how much you use the bad
or the good but but because they're
drawn you know on the symbol because
they're drawn equally perfectly the same
it's up to us to not add to
them so again why I like a much is this
isn't threatening to me or him so it's
an
action but now my mind starts to
go his arms not b and I'm going to give
him a good
Nicko so I'm actually mixing a bit too
much of the black into the
white so if I can
not have too much white either so if I
go I see he's got this thing on so got
be careful with that just ease him down
don't hurt him see now I've got too much
wies so as you go up through the levels
I mean I'm trying to teach you what I
consider spiritual iido in other words
we're trying to get to a place in life
in our daily lives and everything so
that
we do it with a
firmness but not aggression or what not
are you okay just a minute just what I
mean so we mustn't be weak but we
mustn't be bad we mustn't be vicious but
we must be firm when firmness is
required and we must be gentle when
gentleness is
required what you should be trying to do
is not trying to make this part easy and
this
hard because it's not yin and yang it's
aggression so I'm sure that you all nod
and say yes of course we understand that
but when you got them and do it I want
to do a good niio you I mean we all want
to do a good Nicko and that's where the
balance is is wrong so we'll just finish
off with
a
right so I'm sitting Square the last
thing I going to do is take his hand and
do that because I'm not going that way
going that way right so we're sitting
here like this so that's the place I'm
going to go if anything I'm turn that
way so that's the B you didn't quite get
tonight but you will get it in time
you'll find it's more rewarding because
it keeps that firmness that
to better oh